i'm here at craig ranch regional park in
north las vegas and as you guys can see
over my left shoulder children and
adults are having a whole lot of fun in
this triple digit weather playing in the
splash pad and staying cool my little
ones like to get out here in the water
and jump around feel free
local resident martell foster brought
his family to the park to enjoy the
rising temperatures he tells me when
getting out in the heat it's very
important to stay hydrated we come out
with at least about
four waters we have a water before we
leave it's important to get out before
12 o'clock because the peak of the
temperature
rises right around that time which is
why joshua da silva also decided to
start his day in the sun by taking
safety precautions i drink lots of water
a gallon every single day like you're
supposed to
staying under the shade and
really just taking a break very
important measures when playing in the
heat if you don't drink a lot of water
you can
it's really dangerous the sun
it's
dehydrated you end up in the hospital in
north las vegas jeremy j ford live local
now